this could be a movie this guy sets up
first of all among the other
scams that he's already done he sets up
halal capital and investment funds
raises millions of dollars from
investors they don't get paid why
because jay mazzini claims to get robbed
at gunpoint
then he gets sued and his partner is
part of a sworn affidavit
against jay mazzini he's done look he's
done
but i'm here to report to you guys to
watch the dumpster fire that's what we
do here coffeezilla we watch these
scammers we laugh at them
and when they go down we're here we're
here to watch it
all burn down and that's what we're
doing today now without further ado
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i'm your host coffee zilla and today
like i said we're talking about jay
mazzini who has now become really the
coffeezilla
chief clown officer which is very tough
to do we talk about a lot of clowns on
this channel so for him to really reach
that pinnacle first of all
congratulations jay uh second of all
yeah this is a con continuation from
like the giveaway scam from the bitcoin
scam now we're talking about
like capital investment scam
and if i could just ask you guys if
anything look i know you already pumped
the stock you got to pump the zilla
stock respect the pump
but if you could share this video in
particular with anyone who might
be vulnerable to this i know people are
actively getting scammed
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
like literally i
have victims in my inbox all the time
and you know it's absolutely disgusting
so if you could do that if you could
share that to get the word out that's
the only way this guy's gonna go down
now the lawsuit we're talking about
today just remember everything is
alleged uh but there is a pattern of
activity
here so without further ado let's talk
about this scumbag huh
let's go back to the beginning who is
jay mazzini for those of you don't know
well he's mostly just known on instagram
and he portrays his lifestyle of giving
away money i'm such a good guy
i go i go to target or whatever walmart
and give to the kids right
in reality he's using this lifestyle to
launder his reputation to make people
trust him
because he does a bunch of scams that
require you to trust him right
now a lawsuit just came out from the
state of new york
and jay mazzini and some of his uh
cronies are listed in here
where he has now created a whole thing
called halal
capital okay this is for muslims
people of faith and it was a community
uh
like investment opportunity right he
used a guy from the community and this
is so disgusting you guys are gonna like
throw up in your mouth when you hear
about this so he used this guy
nor raba he is a resident of the state
of new york and he was a funeral
director and a community
activist right here funeral home owner
and community activist he met this guy
jay mazzini and jay mazzini used his
background saying he came from
a wealthy family was well known in the
muslim community and everything
wanted to basically give away stuff give
away money to the community
jay described himself as a licensed
financial
professional an expert investor had
grown his wealth several times
then look at this noor spoke of his work
as a funeral director explaining that he
saw his work as a community service and
was well known
to provide free or low-cost funerals to
those
in need so you can think of there's two
characters james and he's saying i'm so
rich i'm so blah blah and then there's
noor who's like this
community activist he's like helping
people who are you know suffering their
worst
loss just a nice guy overall now over
several months they meet up and
basically
uh jay mazzini says look we should set
up something for the community
together as a community trying to better
the community we should set up
something using your financial expertise
uh noirs like um
you know connections with community to
raise
funds for an investment opportunity so
they do this thing called
halal capital noir's role was to raise
funds from his community contacts
and then jay mazzini was to invest their
money now this guy does his job he
collects
millions of dollars from this community
of faith who trusts this guy because
he's the funeral director
meanwhile this guy thinks oh well the
money's in good hands it's in jay
mazzini's hands he isn't he that guy
that helps people isn't he that this is
so disgusting
isn't he that guy that goes to train
stations giving flowers away
like this is the level of sociopathy
that we're dealing with
and literally one of the largest
investors was a mosque in brooklyn
that was seeking a long-term halal
investment that would fund its ongoing
operations if you guys don't know
in in um islam i believe i'm not too
familiar
but i think halal is like you know
things that are okay
haram are things that are not okay to do
so basically this guy's selling himself
is like
i'm the guy who can give you access to
you know great investments
while also staying like holy right and
the point is
is that this went on until people
started asking for their money back
right they're told oh we're making all
this money
so in april 2020 several investors stop
sought to withdraw their funds instead
of
paying them jay mazzini made a series of
excuses by the jabara is jaymenzini's
real first name
including that investments were delayed
by covet 19 pandemic and appealing to
their shared religious background as
evidence of his good faith
whenever noir expressed concern about
the investors funds
jay mazzini would deflect with
references to to his own extraordinary
wealth
at times even offering to personally
guarantee
investments the scheme unravels further
dissatisfied frustrated and concerned
for hc
investors nor became aggressive within
his demands for information from jay
mazzini requesting sit downs with his
family and others ultimately
his responses became so outlandish that
nor determined that judicial
intervention is required so this guy
this community activist who basically
took money from all these people that he
thought he was going to a good place
realizes that this thing's falling apart
this guy's lying he is now
now i realize look i'm responsible for
millions of dollars in my community
and this guy's a con man according to
this lawsuit
the entire fund that he raised was 10
million dollars in funding from people
so this isn't like chump change this
isn't like oh
i had some spare change lying around
that i could afford to lose these are
people's life savings that are invested
with this man
this con man and what do they get out of
it by november 7th
2020 people start to get super
aggressive i mean they've like been put
yanked around forever so uh they're
saying like you gotta pay us
now well the payments were scheduled for
august didn't happen
then august 22nd pay attention guys pay
attention
jay mazzini advised nord that he had
been robbed at gunpoint
hey does anybody buy that so oh i'm
supposed to give you your money i was
going to give it to you but oops
i was robbed i mean this rival's uh
what's his name
oh jesse smilet's whole thing of like i
was like hung by a noose or whatever
like this is that level of like a lie he
says that he didn't
know the exact amount stolen but he
estimated it to be in millions of
dollars
and he said oh oops it was all stolen in
cash and then he had little to nothing
left for payouts
so what is he actually saying there he's
going look
i was carrying around this bag of money
just millions of dollars
it just i guess around what new york
like where is i don't know where this
guy is this
case is in new york uh yeah i was just
carrying a bag of cash that was all the
investors
money i was just carrying it around in
cash why isn't it invested i don't know
he gets robbed at gunpoint goes yeah i
can't pay you i can't
pay you i'd show you the video where uh
he's like talking about this stuff but i
believe it's actually in arabic so i
can't i can't be of any help to you guys
but uh yeah he made this claim on august
22nd
he says that at the time the alleged
robbery occurred his bodyguards happened
to not be present
he claims he filed a report with the
local police department but
today has failed to produce the police
report oops
so do you have a police report or do you
not and at this point i'm sure some of
you guys
are shouting at your screen like how
how is this real i mean it's it's so sad
and it's also
so comically ludicrous look even the
lawsuit itself says it's become
increasingly fantastical yeah that's
kind of true
and now the investors are suing this guy
they're suing jay mazzini for their
money
even though he continues to say oh hey i
acknowledge my failures
i won't let that happen a good again and
be late on the brothers
money is the least of my worries
actually it seems like it's your biggest
worry but here's the craziest part yet
his own partner right this guy who has
been helping the community
he has now signed a sworn affidavit
against
jay mazzini that basically oh yeah this
guy's basically scammed him it's it's
affirming
the lawsuit so think about how crazy
that is the guy he's a 50
stake owner in halal capital remember
was jay mazzini and this guy
and this guy signs a sworn affidavit
that basically says
we've been robbed essentially and that's
essentially what it is
and they're trying to get their money
back but um i'm putting this out there
as a very serious warning to anyone
because jay mazzini is right now
aggressively trying to scam other people
with the bitcoin scam and i'm sure he's
got i mean knowing him he's got a bunch
of other scams going on
because obviously when we thought it was
just the giveaway obviously it was the
bitcoin it was this as well
so please do not give this man
your money share this far and wide his
biggest
audience is on instagram i have zero
instagram audience so if you're on
instagram
please speak out about this yeah i don't
see this going anywhere
but further south for jay mazzini i
think this is going to be a very bad
time for him
but how could you do this to somebody
how could you do this
to a community of faith i mean really
your community at all it's your
community
it's like not even just stealing from
strangers you're stealing from people
abusing that trust in order to take
more money from them how evil can you
be this is so disgusting and disturbing
to even look at that i feel like after
this i'm gonna have to go wash
my eyes out i hate looking at this stuff
right now guys james and he still has
938 000 followers on instagram so
there's a lot more people
still waiting to get scammed please get
the word out thank you so much
for watching thank you for for
supporting we could not get the word out
like we are
without you so thank you so much pump
the stock zilla
and i will see you guys in the next one
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee
[Music]